I am my authentic self and I'm also the
parent my children need me to be for
them we've been married for 13 years now
we've been together for 15 years we have
two children Jonathan and Janette ten
and eight years old we have three kids
so we have four year old twins and eight
year old
family means to me my two dads and my
brother mama
mo pen & batley we've actually been
married for two years this will be your
number three because we were just
allowed to get married a few years ago
before then it was like we would call
each other wife and I would be waiting
for someone to be like you can't do that
which people would say because at the
beginning we were kind of just making it
up and then it was kind like yeah that's
actually what it's called we're actually
married and she's my wife
yeah family is at least two people who
can rely upon each other most people
don't have two dads two moms no one in
that class does one of the things that I
remember when we first had our children
was only be out in public the stairs
that we would get a struggle of sort of
how people vvu is it's a battle every
day and funny enough people will really
like in the elevator ask your questions
about your family and your life I've
also taught my children not all
questions come from a bad place
sometimes a person will ask a question
that they just don't know and they want
to know they love us they want to take
care of us and they want to be with us I
think in some circumstances they will
have it harder in life but in other
areas I think they're gonna be stronger
I mean who better to parent you than
people who had to persevere their whole
life but then you know what they have is
their norm so I don't know that they
would say anything different more
different than any other kids I love you
too have my mama and my mo and my
siblings we are crazy
we are dinner in a show we're never
boring wherever we're at like my
friend's house
um my dad always like starts dancing and
he always makes everybody laugh Dashawn
he wants to always have go shopping
dress-up and always he wants to have fun
with me and Jonathan all the time my
children will be prepared to deal with
the world they'll be prepared to deal
with people who will embrace them and
they'll be prepared to deal with people
who won't embrace them you can get
married you can have kids you can have
all these things it's the best feeling
in the whole wide world to have that
experience there's no one I would rather
parent with especially as a gay parent
other than joy